and what about any metrics or things
that you measured which you thought were
important that weren't so I don't know
if this exactly is what you're looking
for but I can definitely think of
situations where metrics told us a story
that didn't really match reality and one
of these situations we went through a
period of time where our growth was was
really really fast
we were acquiring new MRR our monthly
recurring revenue very very quickly and
we would put that number up on the board
every month and everybody was cheering
and one of the things we started
noticing that while our new mor growth
was going up and up and up our churn
numbers were also grabbed so we had
customers that were falling out of the
back of the pipeline as well and for
anybody who's who's been involved in a
SAS business your churn is is one of the
most important metrics to track because
it means that when it's high you've got
a leaky bucket and you need to work
harder and harder to fill that bucket
while water pours out of it and when we
dug into it it turns out that we we have
been giving our customers we've been
giving new customers a short amount of
time where they could do a trial with us
and then forcing them to make a big
decision after that amount of time was
up and for a lot of these bigger
companies that we've never really worked
with before this just wasn't enough time
and so they would start a trial they
would get to the end of this trial and
they wouldn't be ready to actually
commit or not and they would fall out
they would churn out and so while we
were able to because of these short
trials were able to sort of say hey
there's no commitment up front we were
able to get a lot of new revenue in
through the door we also recreating a
situation where ultimately we didn't
provide a good customer experience and
so that was a situation where you know
we had a we had a metric which looked
really great but there was something
underneath that we hadn't seen that was
pretty important to pay attention to